deep beneath the surface of the zambezi
river in zimbabwe africa
kristen yaldor is trapped in the jaws of
a hippopotamus
as she struggles to free herself the
animal refuses to let go ragdolling her
back and forth hippos wouldn't
necessarily just drag their victims
underwater like a crocodile they're not
predatory species they actually just eat
grass so when kristen
got dragged under water it's likely that
the hippo was actually just returning to
where it's comfortable underwater where
it knew that it had the advantage to
make sure that it eliminated any threat
that it felt from kristin's canoe
i was almost out of air and i started to
re-swallow my air knowing that that
might help me conserve my air in staying
calm and allowing me to
try to survive in this moment because i
didn't know how long this was going to
last the hippo can hold its breath for
two three five minutes kristen being
shook around probably doesn't have much
more than 30 seconds of air and so he's
likely gonna last longer than she is i
had to try something i grabbed its mouth
to try to pry it open
and
didn't budge i'm not strong enough to do
that i instinctively then just curled up
to try to conserve my breath and not be
thrown around so much underwater
and somehow it let me go
it's possible that when kristen grabbed
on to the hippo's snout it actually got
spooked and let go of her because
there's very few
animals that a hippo would have bid on
to that would have had the same reaction
and it's possible that that actually
saved her life chris did
so what seemed like forever i'm
standing there
screaming in a panic and all of a sudden
kristen does pop to the surface
i immediately saw ryan running on the
shoreline with the terrified look in his
face i immediately started to paddle
towards ryan and the guides but i
couldn't swim my leg wouldn't work i
screamed for help
and somehow instinctively turned over
and backstroke
drifting down river on her back stroking
with her arms trying to push herself so
at this point i'm like could this
hippo come back is there a crocodile
upriver was
whatever i needed to do to get over
there to help the guides get her out of
the river so that the the water just
didn't carry her you know continually
towards the falls because you know
that's that's where this this river is
going is is over to victoria falls if
she passes us there's nobody around
i couldn't hear anything i was just
focused on myself trying to get to shore
and then i heard the guide say reach for
the canoe paddle
ryan and a guide pull kristin ashore
where they get a clear look at the
massive damage the hippo did to her leg
when i looked down i could see that my
leg was torn open my skin was ripped off
of my leg and is laying on the side of
my leg and i could see part of my muscle
that was torn off sitting on top of my
thigh hippos have these incredible
weapons in their mouths where they have
these two canine tusks the size of a
flexed human arm but they don't actually
use them to eat what they use the teeth
for is to defend their territories and
to attack other territorial males
kristen at this point is repeating i
need help before i bleed out i knew i
had limited time if i was bleeding out
so my panic and my
instructions to the guides were i needed
help immediately otherwise i was going
to die here
[Music]
you